e aí
e vamos abrir os trabalhos já que a
tenho que ficou messi mais gira no
terreiro e aquela primeira rodada de
bebidas em uma mesa de bar que saudades
vamos abrir os nossos trabalhos e assim
que eu queria começar a nossa fala de
hoje nossa porque é uma fala brasileira
e nossa porque eu não venho sozinha além
de todos os meus antepassados que estão
aqui comigo eu venho junto com mário de
andrade um chá coló
e vem para brindar dizendo saúde
oi e para mostrar que talvez a gente
ainda tenha mesmo motivo para levantar
uma taça e para lutar e talvez esse
motivo seja o brasil contra todas as
expectativas
e aí também para a gente pensar que é
preciso honrar esse brinde no momento em
que a gente atravessa aqui no brasil uma
crise generalizada que é principalmente
mas não só da saúde
o que afetam nosso físico o nosso mental
nós podemos de sonhar nosso moral e que
ameaça a nossa autoconfiança e a nossa
autoestima como povo brasileiro mesmo
minando nossa capacidade de ação e de
reação como tanto querem os nossos
dominadores e os nossos dominantes quase
que a gente não se reconhece mais quase
nos abandonamos e nós não podemos fazer
isso
a gente não pode se deixar convencer de
que se é um país que deu errado como
disse o valter hugo mãe recentemente
escritor português se a gente se
converte se convence de um erro se a
gente se convence disso a gente abre
espaço para pensar que essa é uma
cultura que não têm valor e aí nós vamos
lamentamos a morte de pessoas que
viveram uma vida inteira para construir
ou de jovens que poderiam ter o certo
nós vamos lá lamentamos a perda de vidas
negras indígenas e terras indígenas
absolutamente devastadas
é quase não nos reconhecemos mais e a
gente faz isso como se não valesse a
pena do tá por isso
o que é nosso mas aqui anda tão difícil
né a gente identificar o que é nosso
quem são os nossos um ódio plantado no
meio de nós bonito de povo pacífico que
desencoraja guerreiros
um monte uma pulverização de imposições
lados paixões o que que é que é ser
brasileiro nessa hora é
a gente só pode defender aquilo que a
gente reconhece e para dar um exemplo
básico com o vamos no mercado
um monte de gente saberia dizer se a
great fruit tá ótima naquela hora de
comer ela azedinha mas não saberia dizer
ao pegar um cupuaçu como é que faz para
saber se ele tá maduro soltinho lá
dentro daquela casca
eu não saberia dizer tá pisando em
jurubeba ebute a diário ele z kai pelas
nossas cabeças em quase todas as cidades
brasileiras sabe de cor e salteado
compra sua berry preferida goji berry
clube espere mas nunca experimentou uma
maria pretinha nossa aberta chega mais
um chá boca azedinha
o que mesmo quando o ingrediente é nosso
catuaba
é uma bebida de origem qualidade do
idosa uma árvore quase extinta aliás
guiar com casca escarlate que dá uma
bebida tônica adstringente tem rosa
nossa
oi gente não se reconhece mais
e perdidos em coisas informações que
vende todos os lados a todo dia dos no
meio de tanta sei que horas mas eu trago
verdades nós vamos ter que saber se
reconhecer
é porque o que é nosso é o que nos resta
e o pouco que resta disso eu não tenho
que defender com unhas e dentes porque
no mundo cada vez mais confinado e
asséptico como que a gente tá vivendo o
que é nosso o nosso entorno é só que não
sobra não adianta mais a gente olhar
para a grama do país vizinho ou do nosso
vizinho que não quer mais ele que não
deu um poder pisar lá durante música
nós vamos ter que olhar aqui ó para o
nosso torno para as nossas raízes para
essa terra donde brota os ingredientes
mais incríveis da uva no sul vaia no
sudeste wilon esses ingredientes todos é
o big bang botânico na natureza que
fermento tempo inteiro à nossa revelia
nesse país continente que já abrigou o
pulmão do mundo
eu te aviso a gente pensar que o meio de
uma crise representada pela falta de ar
e a devastação da floresta acontece a
passos largos whats fica pesado o céu
quase cai
bom então a gente vai ter que fazer esse
exercício de olhar no espelho mesmo
reconhecer as rugas mais profundas os
traços mais imperfeitos as covinhas mais
simpáticas se olhar tenta sorrir se
ainda puder
e quem vai nos ensinais caminho de volta
para a gente poder se reconhecer são as
nossas origens a nossa farmacopeia que
não serviu de remédio para o corpo e
para a alma livre de todo mal durante
tanto tempo a cerveiras garrafeiras
benzedeiras matérias os indígenas de
toda a sabedoria os caboclos os
sertanejos os caipiras o fazer
brasileiro
e é só sim que a gente vai conseguir
voltar para casa e são esses guardiões
zelosos os únicos capazes de nos mostrar
o caminho de volta para casa aquele
clarão que abre o meio da marca de
isopor por ali e aí sim já cientes do
nosso valor já devolvidos da nossa
capacidade de ação nós vamos poder lutar
guerreiros que nós somos pelo que é
nosso e não vamos entregar de mão
beijada vidas nem ouro negro floresta
verde mar azul rio doce a quem não
pertence e não merece isso
e não se enganem nós não somos cowboys
nós vamos retirantes nós somos o
barbante que segura o chifre de bode na
vida do armazém do lado das sandálias de
couro dos estilingues das cabaças as
panelas de barro em cima dos fogões a
lenha com cozido mingau baião nós somos
as garrafadas e as ervas em funcionárias
todas
e nós somos suassuna tupi guarani pataxó
nós somos a saliva da índia capaz de
fermentar mandioca aluá mocororó caulim
chibé
e aí foi quando eu descobri que é isso
que a gente tem que engolir com ela
baixo
o que é um de uma pausa na verdade uma
carreira inquietações de jornalismo
depois de uma carreira sólida em
redações nacionais e internacionais para
voltar uma pesquisa sobre o brasil que
eu comecei muito jovem com 17 anos recém
entrado na faculdade de jornalismo foi
contratada para apresentar um programa
de rádio de muitas horas numa rádio que
só tocava música popular brasileira em
curitiba
e embora eu soubesse eu era uma pirralha
mas eu sabia apresenta um programa de
rádio direitinho na época o que eu não
tinha era repertório para conversar com
umas pessoas que apareciam lá para serem
entrevistadas ao vivo baden powell
ariano suassuna dona ivone lara bezerra
da silva e aí eu fui estudar para poder
conversar com essas pessoas
e tchau aprender sobre eles eu descobri
que eu aprendi a sobre a gente isso me
fascinou e foi nessa época ouvindo áudio
blank
o que ele me ensinou que o brasil não
conhece o brasil as nossas querelas as
nossas amarguras desde sempre e aí
depois de formada eu ganhei uma bolsa do
governo britânico para estudar um
mestrado em estudos culturais
latino-americanos para estudar
identidade brasileira na universidade de
londres mas você vai me dizendo que
incoerência né esse da identidade
brasileira em londres mas é que já
naquela época 20 anos ou ainda naquela
época a cultura aqui no brasil não podia
ser estudada pelo viés e pelo caráter
multi e interdisciplinar que ela tem por
natureza a gente só podia estudar
cultura pelo viés da antropologia e não
tem economia da gastronomia dos estudos
de gênero dos estudos de identidade esse
caráter amplo que ela tem eu fui para lá
para estudar isso
ah e também descobri lá uma tese sobre
políticas culturais o quanto às
políticas culturais são essenciais no
momento de crise como que a gente vive
mas aqui no brasil está com raríssimas
exceções na história do nosso país a
cultura ela é colocada e fadado a
universo do entretenimento do sucesso da
leveza
é ignorante da nossa própria história
foi lá também que eu descobri que a
gente tinha engolido muita coisa lendo
ela baixo uma independência que acabamos
amarrando uma coroa usurpadora cruel uma
abolição da escravatura que foi feita
pela metade para dizer o mínimo porque
não deu a menor condição de milhares de
pessoas se integrarem à sociedade de
forma digna o genocídio indígena
camuflado de processo civilizatório nós
vamos ter que olhar para esses defeitos
de fabricação
e agora nós vamos ter que pagar também
para as nossas riquezas então quando eu
retomei esse trabalho sobre o brasil
dessa vez pelo viés dos ingredientes
nacionais e da coquetelaria para deixar
isso vivo foi que eu descobri que eu ia
trazer priprioca que eu tenho certeza
que muita gente está vendo pela primeira
vez fava de aridan ou fava de exu e juca
ah e deixa que esses ingredientes
brasileiros nossos ou trazidos para cá
me mostrassem a caminho dos saberes e
dos sabores nacionais
é porque através deles eu faço uma
pesquisa de sabor sim mas eu uso esses
ingredientes também que a proteção da
nossa cultura inclusive nossos amuletos
e aqui são vírus suvenir de um bioma que
tinha mas acabou
é aquele estejam ingredientes vivos
usados no nosso dia a dia
e não também porque você saberes você já
coisa de gente mais simples coisa de
pobre artesanato cultura popular não mas
memória afetiva re significada vivo e
pulsante saberes recontextualizados
usados todos os dias das garrafadas as
garrafas do bar da mata o copo cerrado
mata atlântica caatinga restinga savanas
pantanal amazônia pampas território
terra terreiro terruá nosso
e foi aí que eu aprendi a fazer coquetel
brasileiro e eu vou fazer um cordéis
para a gente fazer junto e vocês vão
perceber ou fazer o coquetel que tem uma
erva que você já viu o nome que você já
ouviu falar o chá que já procurou por
tua avó tinha no quintal você vai se
reconhecer né
bom então a gente começa a pegando uma
coqueteleira para abrir os trabalhos
finalmentes ou qualquer ingrediente que
tenha um saculejo vai não precisa ter
uma coqueteleira se você não tiver e aí
a gente vai usar mastruço mentruz ou
erva de santa maria que no nordeste no
norte do brasil quando batido com leite
dá um excelente remédio para bronquite
também é servido como refresco
lanchonete junto com suco de graviola
por exemplo de cupuaçu e é uma banda de
forró muito conhecida jornada mastruz
com leite aqui a gente vai usar esse que
foi colhido ontem à noite em parelheiros
aqui na zona sul de são paulo por um
produtor orgânico então a gente vai usar
você tem que tomar batidinha na erva
antes coloca dentro da nossa
coqueteleira para adoçar uma doutora
típica do brasil a gente vai usar o mel
de abelha nativa o mel maturado duros
amarela uma abelha nativa que inclusive
sem ferrão conseguiram sobreviver quando
vieram assis
é óticas para cá e esse é feito pelos
tupiniquins e guaranis em aracruz no
espírito santo então a gente vai usar
também um pouco de mel de abelha nativa
para adoçar
a nossa conta e aí o sítio que vem do
limão cravo galego caipira rosa nosso da
mata atlântica também é
a implantar 25ml se você quiser fazer um
coquetel sem álcool aqui você só coloca
água e pode bater a gente vai usar
tiquira que é um deste lado ancestral
brasileiro com base de mandioca porque a
cachaça é nossa e todo mundo sabe mas
pouca gente conhece adquira feita da
mandioca no maranhão e essa também
orgânica e aí estamos com que a gente
precisa na nossa coqueteleira brasil né
podia entrar catuaba jurubeba borogodó
saravá só não pode entrar o que não é a
nossa cultura na nossa carteira então a
gente vai que eu vou fazer gelo para
bater o céu e essa coqueteleira aqui só
bate na batida do primeiro debate vendo
ela mexe ela treme tocando visível né
gente é
oi e aí quando a gente coloca ela do
nosso copo
e eu costumo dizer que isso aqui não é
um coquetel brasileiro e nem o capital
tropical é um coquetel molotov capaz de
fazer a gente acreditar de volta no
brasil a cada gole é uma bomba
revolucionária isso que é
oi e aí quando a gente finalmente vai
dar o primeiro gole para terminar os
nossos trabalhos a gente tem que honrar
aquela palavra que a gente lembrou lá no
começo que é a palavra que a gente diz
quando a gente era de uma taça aqui
nesse brasil porque a gente olha para
ele se reconhece só que é sangue que
corre na nossa veia é show que a gente
pisa assim e é por isso que a gente diz
quando a gente levanta taça saúde e é o
que eu desejo para todo mundo saúde
e eu sabia que não possa fazer para
todos uma coisa acontecendo que eu
falando e